The aftermath is not always easier.
These are the firemen
of the most bombed city on earth Orikhiv,
in the throes of the counteroffensive.
And this is a normal day for them.
The rest of the year must year for peace
across the year provides
journalism.
Here's the story of one
we've gotten to know.
Dima.
Pain here
doesn't just come from the flames
away from the front lines.
Ukraine is suffering in ways
we don't see.
Dima has lost
nearly all his family
since the war began.
His wife left for europe
as a refugee
just days
after the war started with his son.
And he doesn't know
if they will ever come back.
The emptiness of their family home
is a crippling, constant weight on him.
The gaps between the horror.
Harder than the horror itself.
And sleep when it comes is sometimes
worse.
Orikhiv
has been ground
to dust in the last two months
but Dima's
grief here came immediately
with last year's invasion.
His father died in its first days
just before his wife left
from a heart attack
he says because of shelling
in that chaos.
Dima had to bury his father himself.
He only has his mother left.
She won't leave the house
where his father died
and where Dima was born
and where the flames may strike again.
Nearly
every Ukrainian home has holes in it
from people who won't come back.
And emotions forged in a war with no end
in sight.
That dream of Dima's
the time where now in his sleep
he sees his family again
particularly haunting in a sign, frankly,
the trauma is going through
so many Ukrainian homes right
now, away from the headlines,
away from the violence
and the public seen front lines
Ukraine got some good news today
and over the weekend,
its long held pleas for F16s American
supplied jets
to protect the skies around towns
and potentially assist on the front line
God a step further forwards
Denmark saying they'd send 19 slow
the Netherlands saying
they might send the best part of 42
president Zelensky
and his tour round European country
saying in Greece today
that Greece have agreed
to help train pilots.
We don't know the details there
none of this fast enough though
it won't arrive until next year
and in the next four months
and the summer here
Ukrainians will continue to suffer Wolf.
Nick Paton Walsh reporting for us.
Nick, thank you very much.